if you see a magician sawing a lady in
half and you want to know how it's done
then somebody says well I'll tell you
how it's done they don't really saw the
lady in half they just make it appear
that they're swing the lady now and you
say yeah okay great how do they do that
oh that's not my department that's
somebody else's job I I've already given
you my explanation sometimes
philosophers give answers like that I
think they just don't want to be
bothered they don't want to take on the
responsibility to explain what's
actually
happening what I like to do is explain
things and have them explain to me
mainly explanations are about how things
work why they happen the way they do so
I've been curious about how philosophers
arrive at the positions they arrive at
how
scientists make mistakes when they frame
their own questions I've often said that
philosophy is better at questions than
at answers and that's that's nontrivial
they don't think it's their job to
understand how things actually work
whereas I think that should be the job
of
philosophers I'm Daniel Dennett I'm the
author of more than a dozen books on the
mind on free will on
Evolution and I'm an Emeritus Professor
from tus
University
since I was a little boy I wanted to
know how things worked wanted to take
them apart and see what made them take
what made them work so I was sort of an
engineer at heart and it turns out that
that's not a bad attitude to have as a
philosopher figure out what makes ideas
work and
why and so I've championed the idea that
if you're going to be a philosopher ER
learn about the world learn about the
science I'm happy to say that now
philosophers who are scientifically
trained Way Beyond what I ever was is
growing larger and for the first time in
my career they're being taken seriously
by the scientists because scientists are
just as capable of making philosophical
mistakes or getting into philosophical
confusions as any lay people but they
need the help of informed philosophers
if they're going to clarify those
questions and ask better questions a lot
of people just dig in double down and
refuse to abandon a point of view which
is under attack from their critics that
in itself is not a bad thing I'm I'm
glad that my criticisms are resisted so
resolutely and ferociously by some of
those I criticize otherwise we'd never
get at the truth I think it's very
important to keep in the back of your
mind what if I'm
wrong when I was a graduate student in
philosophy way back in the 60s in Oxford
one day with a group of fellow graduate
students we got talking about what
happens when your arm goes asleep and
you can't control it what on Earth is
that all about and I got interested and
started asking questions about well what
is it is it the nerves do they get
pinched uh is it blood flow what is it
and they thought it was bizarre that a
philosopher would be interested in the
physiological questions of what was
going on they thought I was abandoning
philosophy I went off to the medical
library and tried to get myself educated
on how the nervous system works and that
was a main turning point for me it
suddenly hit me when I learned about
neurons the cells of the brain that do
the signaling that they could be the
basis for an evolutionary process in
your brain which was learning that
learning in the individual was just yet
another darwinian process I didn't know
much about Evolution at the time about
natural selection but I began to learn
and the more I learned the more I
thought this is the key this is the
great key to how things fit together we
get rid of all the magic and we have a
bottomup theory of meaning and learning
and truth and Consciousness and I'm to
this today amazed at how complacent so
many philosophers are with their utter
ignorance of evolutionary theory they
think that if we had a physiological
mechanistic physical explanation of
creativity of Genius of understanding
that this would somehow diminish and
demean these wonderful phenomena not at
all if we understand how amazingly
intricate and wonderful and ingenious
nature is in allowing us to understand
things and create things and think ahead
we would dismiss the magical ideas out
of hand and I think that Darwin's ideas
undo many of the biggest problems in
philosophy or at least subvert them and
turn them into better problems and the
fact that so many philosophers keep
hammering away trying to find the
essence of this or that when Darwin has
shown us that nothing of any interest
has an Essence it's gradualism all the
way this is an idea that is just not
dawned on a lot of philosophers and for
a very good reason they learned from
Socrates from Plato and if the first
thing to do is Define your terms
establish the essence of each thing as
Aristotle would put it and that turns
out to be the great philosophical
mistake forget about Essences learn
about all the variation in the details
in the penumbral cases then afterwards
you'll know what you're talking
[Music]
about one of the most eye openening
moments for me was when I read Richard
Dawkins book The Selfish Gene and
learned about his concept of
memes when Dawkins coined the term memes
he had in mind something very general
the term caught on in the dictionary now
now but only a small subset are what
most people think of as memes and those
are the ones that people deliberately
and presumably intelligently design with
the hopes that they'll go
viral and some of them do but lots of
memes go viral that don't involve the
internet at all words are memes every
word in every language is a meme it's
not genetically inherited it's
culturally transmitted they evolve over
time and Dawkins theory was a very
general theory of how human cultural
Evolution hugely expands the powers of a
human brain in fact I would put it very
strongly I would say the difference
between a chimpanzee and a human brain
is that the brain of a chimpanzee is is
largely unfurnished whereas we fill our
brains with means we download hundreds
of thousands of memes and that's where
we get our power from your your computer
or your phone isn't a very powerful
device until you download some apps to
it those are like
memes we are a washing toxic memes right
now one of the most toxic I think
because it enables so many others is the
idea that truth doesn't matter the truth
is just relative that there's no such
thing as establishing the truth of
anything your truth my truth we're all
entitled to our own truths that's
pernicious it's attractive to many
people and it is used to exploit people
in all sorts of Nefarious ways the truth
really does
matter I think one of my best ideas is
the intentional stance the idea that we
automatically adopt the strategy of
treating anything complicated and
interesting if we can as an
agent what does it want what does it
know what does it believe we use the
intentional stance all the time to endow
other things that are moving and
complicated with the beliefs and desires
and the ability to do the rational thing
given those beliefs and desires well
that's fine as long as we're living in a
world of concrete objects but what's now
happening is is that AI is filling the
digital world with fake intentional
systems fake Minds fake people that we
are almost irresistibly drawn to treat
as if they were real as if they really
had beliefs and desires and these will
be very dangerous memes indeed because
they will replicate they will evolve and
we won't be able to take our attention
away from them they will capture our
attention and
manipulators the difference between
current AI large language models so-call
things like chat GPT and
gp4 is that their goal is truthiness not
truth they are more like historical
fiction writers than historians we're
different in that we take truth
seriously maybe because we want to lie
but llms AIS don't yet really have the
capacity to lie on purpose they do
formulate falsehoods that they then
spread and there's only a difference of
degree between us and them so we're not
used to having our technology in a
position to ignore the truth and just
feed us what makes sense to them
technology have gone to Great Lengths to
make it very hard to make counterfeit
money and quite easy to identify it so
we can do something similar for every
phone computer tablet every digital
device can have software put in it which
will do a pretty darn good job of
detecting counterfeit people and will
not accept it or will brand it instantly
this is fake this is fake this is fan
this is a hoax don't believe it and in
order to do that well you have to have
laws and in order to have laws you've
got to have governments legislator that
will pass the laws and they have to know
enough about what they're doing so they
pass laws that aren't easily
circumvented this is something we have
to work on now and I think we need to
work on it
full-time get smarter faster with videos
from the world's biggest
thinkers to learn even more from the
world's biggest thinkers get big think
Plus for your business